Uh, nice. Right. We're doing it. We're doing it. Nice.
Um, okay, so we're doing it. Nice means absolutely nothing. Uh,
people are nuts about this thing though. Going on how crazy it is.
I went to go get a coffee. And by that, I mean, I was out taking a drive,
not losing my mind, you know, just keeping it nice. So my brain doesn't go.
And all of a sudden I start believing in pizza gate. But what I did was
I stopped in a coffee bean and tea leaf. Now, you know, you know,
if you listened to this podcast from jump that your boy ran that block back in
Sherman Oaks.
And I don't like to talk about it that much anymore because it brings a tear to
my eyes. And I don't have enough toilet paper to wipe the. I mean,
I do now because I thanks for the manager at Walgreens,
but toilet paper is scarce. So, but what I'm saying is, yeah, you just,
you know, I used to keep the block hot. You know, if you know me,
two things I'm down for and sucking in the log cabin.
I love standup comedy. I love my family.
And also the thing I'm talking about, which I forgot.
What was it? The, Oh, I ran, I kept the block hot I'm cold water,
coffee bean. I kept that block. So hot.
I swear to God people thought it was going to erupt. Now that's just the.
That was the word on my block. Now I didn't make that.
That was what people were saying. People said to me,
what's up with this concrete? Why is it says Olin? All right.
Don't want to get into it too much. But I kept that blood hot dude.
I would go BG to go. I would get the Cobb salad. I would hop on over.
Like I was in the children's book. And just walk into that coffee bean,
I'd say hello to an old racist guy. And I'd be like, when I said Americano,
please. And that guy was a racist as. He's probably dead now, but he,
one time he was on a flip phone. Yeah. Yes. I know he's busy,
but I'm trying to get in touch with the mayor. Yes, I understand. I know.
But I want to talk to the mayor about what he's doing with all these illegal
immigrants. Okay, cool. That's what he said. So that's how you know,
this coffee bean was hot as, but this guy, one time a guy came in with a,
I don't even know what to call that. I don't want to be racist,
but it was a black guy. And he was wearing one of those things that just,
you don't see in America, you see in like Africa, maybe he was African.
I have no idea, but one of those things, that was just one piece that,
but all wrapped around, it was like, Trump's hair, you know,
we're like start somewhere, but you don't know where,
but that's what this African guy was wearing. Just one piece, no pants,
no shirt, one piece that was just wrapping around his, his shoulder, his feet,
you know?
And he was just floating in like Orco from He-Man and he got the thing
and the racist guy, the old guy said, Hey.
Uh, when in Rome? Huh? And.
Well, what's this about?
He says when and Roma and the guy says, excuse me, sir. Yes. He says,
why don't you dress us? And I go,
I knew what was going to happen.
I knew that the guy being talked to is going to be so peaceful,
just because of what he's wearing.
People who wear stuff like that are super peaceful.
You know what I'm talking about? Uh, the more articles of clothing you have,
the less peaceful you are. Like if you have one thing wrapped around a Toga,
or if you're wearing nothing, you know how peaceful you are.
If you just have a leaf around your, but this old guy had on jeans,
shoes, a button down, walking shirt over it,
and also a briefcase. He would bring a briefcase,
like an old-school one that looked like a Lego, like a briefcase, not a duffle,
a briefcase, put it on the table, open it up.
Like it was the that pulp fiction centered around with the gold inside of it.
And he would open it up and I, you not, dude,
this guy would pull out ness quick in his briefcase and
whatever he got from the bar, he would put nest quick in it, stirred around,
put it back in his briefcase case, close it up. All right. Now here's the thing,
you know, that guy's racist just from the briefcase.
But this guy came in and the guy goes like this when in Roma. And he says,
excuse me, so what he says, why don't you dress like us? You're a far from home.
This is America. And the, and the guy said, I, you know what, I,
I should, I, why don't I? Yeah, maybe I should. Yeah. You know what to say?
But then he was like, I pray for you, sir. And he left and I was like, God dude,
to be that outwardly racist before Trump is
crazy. All right. Anyway, I kept that blog. Huh?
And uh.
The coffee bean has become my main state.
And I've been through a lot of with coffee bean, man.
Sometimes I drink the coffee. When I first got out the car, I was like,
the coffee sucks. And then I started liking it.
And then I started drinking different coffee that people were like,
but this is the hot. I don't like the boutique coffee shops that often,
often overdo their. And I'm not about that life, dude.
And I'm also not about the sweet Brown,
like the brownie put the Dunkin Hein in the oven. I'll scarf it down. You don't,
I don't want extra on the thing. I want to go to a gourmet place. You know,
there's always like some new place popping up in LA. That's just like, Hey,
you got to check out. It's just the artisinal ice cream place. Oh yeah.
Put the hog and dies in my mouth. I'm not taking. Yeah.
But they give you a pretzel to scoop it out with and you eat it with the
pretzel. Oh yeah, go yourself. Ice cream has been around for years.
Centuries ice cream has literally been around for billions of years, literally
billions of years,
billions of ice creams all around the world from different times.
And um, anyway, I take my ice cream.
Haagen-Dazs one time I was in a mice.
My mom's suburban as a high school kid and my, and my, and, and one of her, uh,
cousins, uh, sons was over and he was so funny. He's from New Jersey.
And my brother said, uh, my brother's talking about how a girl liked.
And he said, yeah, well, I can't help it.
She wanted my Haagen Daz and my friend from New Jersey. Oh,
you got hugging guys back there.
And I pulled over and laughed, dude,
I got Haagen Dass back there. Ah,
Oh, man. I love like that. So anyway,
I keep the black hot coffee bean and I we've been together, dude.
We're an odd couple. You understand? So, um,
so I go to this coffee bean during this
pandemic, I got my N 95 mask on. I got my hands in my.
You know, I'm touching doors. If I have to, if I'm not, I don't.
If I'm with someone, which I never am, I haven't touched, you know, my friends,
I go like this, you open it, you get it. You'll get it. You get COVID
and they go, all right. I guess I'm, you know,
maybe going to get COVID and I walk into the thing and I got my N 95 mask and my
buddy Mark, is there. The guy who opened for me sometimes, and he's Irish.
And he goes like this a lot. Oh, seriously. Or begins every sentence with here.
Here. What time is the show? Why'd you say here at the beginning of that,
why are you adding words? So I'm there. And a guy walks in with a mask,
a mask, you know,
one of those ones that nurses wear and also a headband
with a glass shield over it homemade. Now the guy's in his seventies. Okay.
And I respect it. I'm like, all right, this guy is taking this COVID.
Seriously. He's also a little bit older, more at risk, you know,
maybe Brian Callan's age. And I'm like, that's great.
So he says to,
so, Oh, by the way, Mark is a color that doesn't exist.
I should have started this with this.
My friend Mark is a color that doesn't exist yet.
Do you understand? He's a mix of translucent
and beige. Okay. It was like the movie,
remember the movie powder, how the guy was so white,
like Mark would have auditioned for this. And they would have been like, well,
we need it to be more believable.
So we're going to use the guy and just put actual makeup on him.
We want people to watch it because Mark looks like a potato
that we left out too long. You understand?
It's so, and his head hair are pubes. So he, uh,
yeah. So, so like when he gets a haircut, they say, what do you, when he says,
you're a pubes. And so, um,
so he is always translucent and beige. Okay.
And he's because of this,
there's definitely something going on with his immune system.
And Mark's been sniffling since I've met him since I've met him. Yeah.
I'd be like, Oh, Kira.
And you're just like, is that a, not just an Irish thing? Like, I don't know.
So he's doing his Mark and the
70 something year old says, Hey man,
you're sniffling from across the coffee bean. And I go, I miss this place,
man. This guy's the new racist. The sky. This block is hot.
Now coffee bean is where it's at.
There's always one crazy person in a coffee shop. And when that person leaves,
ding, ding, ding, another guy comes in and is like,
you guys heard of pizza gate. So this guy says, Hey,
you're sniffling. And Mark says something that I understand,
but the guy doesn't understand because when Mark talks for the first time to
somebody he's inaudible because he's so Irish. My brother,
I remember once, um, my brother, when he met Mark,
Mark said something like here [inaudible] and my brother said what?
Jeff's like that. And I fell out, okay. Now, uh, this guy said, Mark says, uh,
here, uh, it's just, it's nothing. And the guy says what you shouldn't be out.
And Mark goes, it looks at me. And he's like, nah, it's just sniffling.
It's nothing. I, I don't have it. And I'm like.
Oh wait. Oh. Yeah. COVID.
And so, um, so the guy says, yeah, you're sniffling. You shouldn't be out.
And I'm laughing, dude, because your boy's a near dwell.
I'm loving it. I'm like this.
I'm like a goalie before they drop that soccer ball in. Right.
And, uh, and he, um, and he says, yeah, you, you,
you, you, you, you, if you're compromised, you shouldn't be out in public.
You should be wearing a mask at least. And I'm like, Hey man, he,
he doesn't have it. He's, always, I've known the guy for ever.
He doesn't have it. He's, he's always sniffling it as annoying as.
It's one of his things. It's a tick I said, and the guy says, yeah, well, I'm,
um, I'm 72. So, you know, if I get it, it's bad news. And I was like, buddy,
it's all good. Don't worry about it. And that was when I was like, man,
I could really see this going and getting out of control.